my name is Tony fast um is this working
yeah okay and I'm a developer at
continuum analytics I work as a data
scientist and a lot of what I want to do
is get data on the page in a meaningful
way and I've been working a lot with
bouquet and bouquet kind of gives me
some really interesting interactions and
expressions that I can do visually with
data um one of the examples and I'm
going to show just because I think it's
really pretty is using playing with
color playing with alphas and playing
with different kinds of zooming and
colored features of bouquet while I'm
moving around in a plot and exploring it
gives me some really rich color some
really rich interaction and it's a
little bit novel compared to most of the
JavaScript libraries that I've used
before so I've been working at continuum
and I've been exposed to a new tool set
and it's really curious to think about
going back to your old work with a new
tool set so in I come from material
science and I've worked in manufacturing
for a very long time and one of the
things that we do is we look at
microscope images and on the screen
right now are 12 different microscope
images of alpha beta titanium titanium
is a heavily used product of
manufacturing and the processing are the
way it's heated the way that it's rolled
the way that it's made has a really big
impact on how the material not only
looks where each of these images come
from different experiments different
processing techniques but also has a big
effect on how it performs now the
microscope is to the 120 130 of these
pictures so they realistically can't go
through and explore all of these so
using some data science methods and
using bouquet we can create a really
rich visualization that actually gives a
very very strong image comparison of
these of these images so we have 12
different processing steps which give
all of these different feature
structures of the images we do a little
bit of Statistics to create a reduced
embedding of them and then I get down to
a projection of all of the data um and
what we're looking at here is each color
is actually a experimental method or
processing method for making this piece
of titanium
the processing method that you use makes
different kinds of titanium to use a
different processing method you get a
different kind so we want to explore
these images really well each point here
is a reduced embedding of a microscope
image and it's reduced to a XY
projection but each of these points
actually represents a picture and I want
my microscopy so my manufacturers to be
able to realize that so the ability
using using the zoom features and adding
some alpha fading to this actually
allows me to zoom in and the nearness of
the pictures and the overlapping of the
pictures actually tells me something
very similar about them or different
about them depending upon how they're
moving from each other so at this point
here we can see that this is from heat
treatment 27 which is what HT indicates
same thing here so zooming in we can see
the images that are responsible for
those embeddings this note books
available online I put it on my Twitter
stock fast first link there this this
notebook runs on NB viewer all of this
is available in the client using some
bouquet using some JavaScript and using
the using Jupiter you're able to present
a really rich client-side application
that's data backed on the web shareable
by a link I'm I'm Leland mcinnes can you
run here yep good okay from the Tata
Institute from mathematics and computing
and Canada and i'm i'm interested in
clustering and i'm interested in just
exploratory data analysis and that has
slightly different needs on clustering
so first rule of data science is look at
your data because real data is messy and
you're probably wrong about it and
there's probably some outliers they're
screwing you up so start up look at your
data see control of data science no
really look at your data because you're
probably wrong you know you probably
have some people who are you know
subject matter experts who know all
about the data and they're going to tell
you things about the data that they know
are true those are almost certainly
false
as a rule that's that's what I've found
in whenever I've dealt with this so
really look at your data so that's great
how do I look at my data well there are
a million different things you can do
visualizations a good start but
depending on what data you've got
there's all kinds of different ways you
can go about getting some sense of
what's going on in your data to try and
understand it better so out of all of
those I'm going to focus on clustering
so what should we sure what should we
use for clustering well obviously
k-means know all right so this is my
rant part never use k-means for
exploratory data analysis there are
places where k-means make sense I'm not
personally sure where they are but I'm
sure they exist but for starters k means
is not a clustering algorithm it's a
partitioning algorithm it partitions
your data it doesn't assign things two
clusters it assigns everything to some
cluster so even if you've got noise
you've got outliers you got random
corrupt data points they're going to get
assigned to your clusters with you want
them there or not and that means when
you go and look at your data with
k-means clusters you're going to be
wrong because it's going to have miss in
your cluster that's going to screw up
all your intuitions about what's going
on k-means also assumes that your data
is going to cluster into nice gaussian
balls now that's probably true if you do
the right transformation on your data to
get it in the right form but if you can
do that you're probably already done
because you understand your data really
well so that's probably not the case and
choosing the number of clusters for
k-means that's a lot harder than you
think real dad is messy and yeah there
are clustered goodness measures but
their diverse and often wrong so there's
really no good way to get a handle on
what the number should actually be other
than you know kind of guessing so what
do we need from clustering for
exploratory data analysis well the first
thing is don't be wrong I don't care if
you don't get everything right I don't
care if you say I don't know just don't
lie to me because that will ruin my
intuitions and then I'm going to
misunderstand the data from there on it
so I want something that's going to be
conservative and try and give me as
close as it can to the right answer and
just say I don't know in whatever places
it can't work things out it's going to
have as few parameters as possible and
those go to be intuitive parameters that
I can just guess without having to do a
whole bunch of exploratory data analysis
to work out what my parameters should be
class rings have to be stable I don't
want when I rerun it I don't wanna get a
completely different clustering if I
resample my data I don't want to
completely different clustering if I
tweaked my parameters a bit I don't
expect that to give me a completely
different clustering and we need
performance and scaling to large data
sets so if not k-means then what so what
am I proposing well DB scan is a
perfectly good algorithm that meets a
lot of these criteria it's already an
ASX learn so that's great it's very very
fast and it clusters instead of
partitioning it's a little hard to pick
the parameters for it but it's something
robust single linkage is a better option
if you're interested in the cluster
hierarchy it's a version of single
linkage that's robust to outliers if
you'd never heard of it look into it
there's some links there right and down
quickly it's a great way to go and you
can get really quite good performance
depending on the implementation and the
third option that I'm going to suggest
is HDD scan which is kind of like
reverse single linkage with an extra
step that pulls out a flat clustering so
the end result is very similar to DB
scan but you're down to just one fairly
easy to choose parameter really so
that's all I have and hopefully that's
important thanks I my name is Adam I am
a second-year grad student at Yale
University and and i signed up mostly
for the adrenaline but also to give you
like a summary of two years of my data
science in the wild but i'm going to
talk about depression depressions an
extraordinarily important issue over 300
people million globally have depression
and it's really expensive to treat right
workplace costs sorry it's a really
expensive issue workplace costs
associated with people leaving work for
depression
costs fifty two billion dollars per year
in the united states alone the question
of what we do about it is the problem at
the moment there's two main approaches
one of them is to use drugs called
antidepressants but the efficacy of
these drugs is notoriously low between
11 and thirty percent of people actually
get better when they take these drugs
even after eight to twelve months of
treatment but it's okay right we have
loads of different antidepressants so if
it doesn't work you should just try
another one and sounds like a joke but
that's actually what we do and and it
works for most people eventually in
theory that's not such a bad problem but
the problem is that people reach the
correct antidepressant through a
completely trial and error process and
it would be really nice if they didn't
have to go through this treatment by
treatment sequential selection problem
and we just had a way of estimating
before they take a drug whether they
were going to get better or not I'm
going to skip through some Slough
because these are old slides and so the
data that we have is taken from an old
clinical trial called star d it's the
largest ever clinical trial of
depression and they enrolled 4,000
people and the only point that you need
to know about this trial is that all
4,000 people started out on the same
drug it's a common antidepressant called
citalopram and because this trial has
already finished we know the outcomes
for this trial right so 4,000 people
went through this they all took the same
drug and our outcomes a pretty easy to
label and basically the green people are
people who after 12 weeks of treatment
were no longer depress so this is kind
of like the clinical objective and so
what data do we have to predict these
outcomes I went through the trial and
extracted all the information that was
collected about these patients that was
available at baseline it included things
like demographics diagnostic questions
and load of questions questionnaires
that they filled out about their
symptoms the problem here is that now we
actually kind of have too much data for
a simple model we need some way of
constraining this problem most of you
will probably be familiar with this we
use a method called elastic net
regularization and this was a
cross-validated model and we basically
threw everything in
then rank the absolute beats ways to
take the top 25 we now use the top 25 we
now use those top 25 features sorry
about this it's kind of painful we now
use the top 25 features to train a
gradient boosting algorithm but
generally it doesn't make a difference
which model use and the questions that
are identified by this process were
generally meaningful it was things like
at baseline depressive severity their
current employment status and a couple
of specific symptoms that they
experienced like I said sorry we trained
gradient boosting model to try and
predict these outcomes using the
baseline information and statistically
it worked we end up with sensitivity and
ppv in the order of sixty three sixty
four percent you have to bear in mind at
baseline we only expect 11 to thirty
percent of these patients to remit so if
our model thinks they're going to remit
they now have between a two and six
times greater chance of remitting the
model performance is probably best
considered against the performance of
actual clinicians so we got a sample of
practicing psychiatrist that did their
residency at Yale to predict at
treatment outcomes using the same data
you can see this was the distribution of
responses that we got the dotted line in
the middle was chance performance
obviously most of the clinicians below
that and the model that we built was in
the top right hand corner which was the
same as the as the best performing
clinician I mean we train the the the
model on 4,000 patients right so it's
not super surprising so any case we
think that we have a model and it's kind
of better than clinicians and we then
wanted to we need some kind of
confidence that the model generalizes so
we went and got an independent clinical
trial that was run six years later it's
a little bit smaller they only enrolled
665 patients and they were spread across
three treatments kind of give us an
interesting opportunity to test model on
some other samples the model did have
above chance accuracy when we tested it
on a similar antidepressant it also
worked when that antidepressant was
combined with a different antidepressant
but it did not work in a third treatment
arm where patients took
a combination treatment of two different
classes of drugs I'm going to skip all
of this to take our message from that is
that you don't have to predict whether
they got better you can predict specific
symptom changes as well so the take-home
message is that I'm trying to convince
people in the clinical world that
statistical models might help guide
medication choice in depression we're
now doing some work to try and model
changes on specific symptoms rather than
the overall outcome and we're also
extending this approach to other mental
illnesses I have some academic
acknowledgments but realistically the
only people that we should be
acknowledging the people who develop
these open open source data analytic
tools because without them we wouldn't
be able to do this but thanks a lot guys
okay so this talk I have nothing up my
sleeves at all so we start with a C
Python built from source it's 3.5
because ubuntu doesn't come with 3.5 in
the package manager so i had to build it
from source so all I'm going to do is
make install so I'm going to start with
a brand-new unaltered unmolested Python
3 now while this is installing I will
tell you that I tried to do this at
PyCon Canada for a 35 minute talk on
Saturday it failed miserably it was the
worst Hawk I've ever given in my entire
life I was so embarrassed and so ashamed
so hopefully it'll work better right now
so here what we can see is we have a
Python 3 and we have pip I'm going to
pip install a module that's on pi PI
it's called our watch and we'll see if
this works give it a second okay it
seems to have worked so now we'll run
our Python interpreter Python 3 and see
if it look watch we just want to
to that okay and here we have this it
created a module called our watch now
you might wonder what our watch does
well it adds some stuff to the cyst
module get our watch and set our watch
what do set our watch and get our watch
through well we'll type help this gets
the target set with cysts thought set
our watch that's not very interesting
let's see what set are watched us set
read watches for the specified objects
well what on earth is a read watch well
some of you maybe see developers and may
have played around in gdb and sometimes
you find that you don't want to debug
some code by putting a break point on a
line of code you want to debug some code
by figuring out what's happening to the
data you may have millions of data items
being sent into some system and one of
those data items is causing an error so
you want to say whenever that data item
is read put a breakpoint that's what a
read watches and we seem to have been
able to add this to python so let's take
a look and see how this works let's
create a variable 10 let's create a
watch just some call back all it does is
print saw this object at this frame
and return the object will set the our
watch for that object and this function
and every time we try and access that
variable it triggers our code that's
kind of interesting let's create a
function it takes an X and returns x and
x times 2 let's call it with our X
variable that we set a read watch on
look it targets three it triggers at
three times one and when you pass it to
the function and twice inside the
function itself so every time you try to
access this variable in any way
whatsoever to read it in any way
whatsoever you can hook into that and
have some custom code well that's kind
of interesting I wonder what else you
could do with that what if you wrote
your watch like this no well that's kind
of interesting every time I have to I
have to reset the watch let me reset
that watch and actually before I do that
let me make just two little simple
bindings now I'll reset the watch now
every time I try and access x I get a
runtime error that's interesting that's
kind of like Sam boxing if I try and
access why why should be if I try and
access the elements at Z which are
include x I get nope and I can't seem to
access the variable at all I can't print
it I can't pass it to a function I can't
read it from a function I can't do
anything with it because the watch just
raise an exception that's kind of
interesting read watches can then lead
to Sam boxing well I wonder what else I
could do with this well one interesting
thing that you saw was I returned the
object I wonder what kind of interesting
stuff I could do if I return something
else
oops let's do that one more time and get
the indentation levels just right okay
now one also thing you may one other
thing you may have seen is when I set
our watch I could pass any mapping so
what if I did this
so now it triggers this watch on
everything and any any any variable that
I give it so if I give it the number one
it becomes to get number two comes for
let's uh let's make this a little bit
i'll show you because you can't see the
side of the screen so high that so you
can see one becomes two two becomes four
four becomes eight sixteen becomes 16 x
equals or so one plus one is now equal
to 4x equals 1 x plus x is now equal to
eight that's kind of weird and that
could probably ruin somebody's day but
if I may have a second more there's one
more kind of neat thing you could do
with this some of us come from
backgrounds where we are originally Java
programmers or C programmers or C++
programmers and one of the first things
we wonder about python is what happens
all the pointers could we use this to
add pointers into Python well maybe we
could and let's give that a try and then
I'll kick myself off the stage so we
have two variables x and y we have a
function that makes a pointer now this
is a little bit a little bit hokey
because we have to do some mechanics to
make sure that the watch doesn't trigger
itself one thing that you may wonder
after i get off the stage is what kind
of twisted mind must i have to come up
with this in the first place
okay so let's say Z and Z at is equal to
making a pointer on X let's set up our
watch
now every time I access see that
variable redirects me to the variable X
and I can repoint z @ y and access at ya
simple pointers in about six lines of
code now the really interesting thing
that I don't have time to get into is
how on earth did I did this did I do
this in an important module how do you
add this to Python an in portable module
something that you can pip install on
any Python 3.5 as long as it's not on
Windows think about that and maybe you
can see my talk later our program thank
you so much all right so I'm going to
talk about a concept called abstract
rendering I don't know if I'm actually
speaking into the mic or not so plotting
is good plotting helps us understand
what our data is doing helps us make
decisions based just off the plot you
don't necessarily in a computer that you
can look at the plot and determine what
your data actually looks like plotting
lots of data is hard so if I was to take
the census data from the 2010 census
that's about 300 million people plus
some change and just plot that with a
matte plot lib this is approximately
what it would look like so we have a lot
of saturation on the East Coast and a
lot of white space on the wesker like
the Midwest that's just because we're
plotting the data we're taking the data
point we're mapping it to a glyph so a
point and it's over saturating in each
pixel and so we're not getting a lot of
intuition based off this and if we were
actually to change our plotting this and
plot where we're clipping in black it
looks a little like this as you can see
all of the black bits are over saturated
and all of the gray bets are under
saturated meaning that they were moved
to white when they're applauded if you
were scaled inland on so that's not a
very informative plot just plotting like
this so there has to be some way we can
go back to getting intuition like we
normally would when you're plotting a
small amount of data but plotting lots
more and so one solution is abstract
rendering it's a concept that came out
of this paper by Joseph qadam and Peter
Wang and
I can't remember the other guy I
apologize to them but the link is right
here from Iowa there no Indiana and so
the basic concept is to take the data
move it to an aggregate of some form and
then have that map to an image and so
one example would be to take the data
points so each person count by people
that are going to be mapped to that
pixel and then do a log scale by pixel
me do a log scale based on the Weber
fechner law so linear scaling some kind
of intensity gives to an exponentially a
visual so perceptually visual change
from white to black but doing it with an
exponential increase in brightness just
agree to linearly and so we can actually
get a better perception of what's going
on so if you actually look at this on
the top we have a linear scale and on
the bottom we have a exponential scale
and so you can see the difference maybe
not on this monitor haha anyway that is
from this phenomenal website right here
it's a great lecture on color if
anyone's interested and so I have a fun
demo which hopefully will work
oh boy
okay hopefully this works out as it did
on that computer so this is um this is
the census data being plotted using the
concept of abstract rendering so what
we're doing here alive is we are
aggregating by count as I mentioned and
then taking the log of the data and so
you can actually get a much better
visually perceptive understanding of
what's going on with this and so the
point I'm trying to get across is that
you can still actively plot large
amounts of data you just have to think
about how you're doing it you can't just
map directly using matplotlib or some
other plotting library you have to think
about how to possibly agree if they did
it and still get meaning from it um if I
have a little more time I can show some
other fun things if we zoom in on New
York this is going to rerender cool so
this is all done with Python the code is
unfortunately an open source hopefully
that gets changed it gets pushed to get
up at some point in the future cool so
there's new york city we can actually
change the last step there so we've
computed aggregates we've done count
buys I've actually counted by a race
this has got it grouped down into five
different races race groupings so if I
do a different final step we can
actually see New York City colored so
blue is white green as black red is
Asian orange is Hispanic and brown is
other and so you can see New York is
extremely colorful see if we zoom in on
where we are
a little bit
let's see I'm trying to give other fun
things to do so Detroit all right
got a bit
gonna take a second there we go so
that's Detroit
yep um let's see what else could we do
here if i zoom out let's get the whole
map
so this is all running Python code in
the background this is change from an
old Java server this is now move to one
hundred percent it's like 400 lines of
Python and should hopefully get put up
on github sometime soon so this is the
standard composition this is saturating
if we were to do a linear scale so just
go from min to max this is what it would
look like it's almost all just one shade
of pink and if i turn off labels you can
see a tiny red spot for New York so
that's not nearly as useful as doing the
log scale that's about it unless anyone
else wants to see something else that's
not in my talk my name is Richard postal
Nick and I'm a developer for continuum
analytics my backgrounds in financial
engineering so today I'm going to
present a demo on calculating credit
valuation adjustment using monte carlo
and number credit valuation adjustment
is a way to price a derivative and
instrument and account for counterparty
default so this is the likelihood that
someone that you have an arrangement for
that the person that bought your product
your credit product likelihood that
they're going to default on the deal
that you made together and before the
financial crisis this wasn't really
something that was looked into and is
now part of the basil three requirements
that banks have to calculate while I'm
looking at it here is that calculating
CVA on a firm-wide level at a whole Bank
things have millions of credit products
they have thousands of counterparties
each with their own inherent risks so
doing a Monte Carlo simulation of this
type it can become a very big problem to
try and calculate and trying to write
this in Python might be a little slow
but let's see how we can write it in
Python and get some sea speed using
numba so first I start off by generating
random bake data I'm working with two
products here the two power
I'm going to calculating the simplified
example our foreign exchange and swaps
so here I just generate some random data
about the counterparties the hazard
rating so the likelihood of default as
well as the size of the deal the deals
being the credit instruments the
interest rate of the deal the swap rate
for the deal and whether it's in u.s.
dollars or in Euros so this is all done
in basic Python here I'm not doing
anything fancy because this is just
generating in order to deal with the
example so here we go and we just didn't
generate some numpy arrays with filled
with our deals each one being assigned a
random counterparty randomly assigned
their values this kind of what a single
deal looks like here it just becomes a
bunch of numbers we I've what's it
called enumerated the types of deal so
this would say this is a foreign
exchange product as opposed to saying
putting in a string right here because a
number gets a little weird with data
types they have to use so here I
enumerated makes a little simpler here I
generate my random normal curves for
doing the Monte Carlo simulation
estimating out the time steps producing
the normal steps that we're going to use
to calculate the price of the
instruments in each time step and then
here is the whole Monte Carlo function
right here and this is all in pure
python using numpy actually here it's
not really using anything this is just
pure python it's going to take in out in
ray of the deals some parameters that we
want to pass in and in number you have
to pass in the result if you're going to
use this GU vectorized function which is
what i'm using here to compile this to
see in
sex so the result of this I ran this in
Python originally it took about 10
minutes this still working process but
when I ran it in number they took about
two hundred milliseconds so that's a
very big difference and when I skip this
was only with a couple of thousand deals
in reality you know I would want to
scale this up to two million a couple
million deals and see how that works so
yeah so here this says this number this
point 039 i scaled the number down to
say okay so about four percent of our
total portfolio is likely to be in
default so we're going to lose about
four percent of this total value so I
don't want just one number that doesn't
really tell me anything I want the speed
so that i can calculate this number
under many initial or changing my
initial conditions and see how that
affects our my cv a calculation so here
just to look at the data the random data
that are generated this kind of shows
the break out of the rating of the
counterparties how they were generated
and allocated you see that there's about
fifty percent with zero corresponds to a
rating and 4 corresponds to e see here I
want to see what happens with different
level volatility so going from 0 to 1
and calculating CVA over each for each
one now I can kind of see how my CV a
number will change as I change
volatility here it's not too interesting
because there's a very simplified
calculation so it's linear relationship
same thing here I want to see what
happens when I start with different with
a different interest rate kind of see a
little convexity in the curve here and
glean some information from that
sorry it looks like the bottoms cut off
but why we want this is I don't want to
just look at one number i want to look
and see how i can go and know how my
number will change under different
scenarios and this took me a day to
write write in python using numpy numba
bouquet don't have to write any
JavaScript no HTML no see nothing and in
one day you have a tool that people can
use but everyone and this is your talk
ago I gave a week ago in Chicago in high
frequency trading conference and it is
an hour long and I'm going to compress
it to five minutes so it's going to be a
bit fast so basically what we're going
to do is we try and [ __ ] forecast you
know market prices because money now how
we going to do that well basically we
need to actually sleep see what is the
time serious I'm serious is a trend and
noise good let's continue now now what
we want to do is just basically forecast
the future now how we going to do that
well i'm pretty sure that most of you if
not all of you is familiar with linear
regression basically you get samples you
try and find a line that represent those
samples now if you take that and put
that on a time seriously you won't get
good results so what do you do basically
what you basically a good technique is
to take this time sears and make
sequence and then apply your model to
that now yeah we have just done
supervised learning which is not
interesting and actually it is because
all right my last function is our
missing good so what I want to show you
is what happened when you do that well
you actually get pretty poor result
now this is because we didn't take
something in consideration the time
series is not stationary now how do you
stationery how do you how do you perform
stationer station realization to a time
series well there are many methods and
basically what you do is you transform
it somehow so good let's transform it
somehow with you know that
transformation why is that I don't have
time good let's continue now now I want
to point out something which is for us
humans that thing might be pretty hard
for you know having any sort of you know
prediction of what's going on with that
but all right before I put that to the
algorithm argument i'm going to show you
the algorithm full structure is you take
the time serious transform it to chop it
up two sequences put it in through a
learning model and you know can get it
reverse the transformation and you get
your prediction now that's such
information now when you do that with
the transformation and without the
transformation you get really better
results with the transformation and we
didn't even get to you no more
complicated models now why use linear
regression why not polynomial regression
good actually nothing stops us so let's
do it let's do so if you take the same
transformation with polynomial
regression of you know degree 5 you get
better results so why not degree 99
because of overfitting overfitting
really easy we can pretty see that those
land those samples representing a line
and if we try and use a to complex model
to predict those lines if it will come
up with something like that and each
prediction of the next sample is going
to be here which is not good if you want
to invest your money in that and I have
no time but actually I got a really good
demonstration of a back testing strategy
based on that algorithm and you can see
your money just go down and down
down and down and down good let's
continue so basically how you do how do
that cross validation everyone here
should be familiar with it what we did
here is we searches we searched for
constant that you know represent our
data good so why not take that and go
make it you know to the function at the
end so this is where get the perceptron
the artificial neuron and if you stack
them up you get and you will network
good so why only one layer no reason
let's put more layers and see what
happened alright so when you train more
layers you can actually see that you get
good results so why only two layers when
you can have a lot of layers well you
cannot have layers forever all right if
anyone think that you can just go it
look like while one layers and
everything will be all right it's not
gonna work that way every layer adds a
lot of work of regulation and everything
in so on and so on but if you take a
really deep network well there are many
many researches about that and you can
get really good results only by that
without them actually having more
complex and insane models like I have in
the next slides which I'm not going to
talk about so when you do that you get
even better result results now the only
thing i want to show you guys because of
time is what we did here is we took the
input and just give it to the network
what happens when we you know prep
process it a little bit now the most
simple thing we can do with you know
linear time series and it's just compute
the technical analysis indicators and
see how that works for a mole and we can
see that our model performed really good
after that and the rest of the talk is
about how to make it more insane and
every layer does something else and so
on and so on and so on and I have not a
lot of
so yeah